[Music]
but in geo barbell how's that been going
[ __ ] sucks shut down for two months
yeah no money coming in at all zero
online soon pretty good so online is
still cool which is awesome
apparently are supplements so like I
think we have pretty cool international
fan base and everyone's like a big
supporter so that's been awesome but
then the gym itself so how are you
working on your comedy if the gym isn't
okay I get this reference I watch when
I'm not on well you watch more than I do
i watch enough because he's fitness and
comedic stuff comedian but why you ask
him because um governor Newsom has
recently announced that slowly but
surely gyms will soon be open yes all
right that's sort of nothing they're
saying possibly by next week oh yeah
what I'm not very caught up on all the
[ __ ] you know what I have been noticing
is there's a lot more governors and
mayors that are looking kind of sexy
Hardy attractive like Newsom thank you
six years six years well we've always
had hot governors I gotta say yeah wheat
wall
but before Arnie you got great Davis
sexy man he was sexy
he was pretty standard but Pete Wilson
dope I don't know
but Newsom Newsom must be sexy though a
little hot older men jokes they're poor
you what who the [ __ ] is great dance but
yeah so they have announced the four
stages in case you guys don't know stage
one is the stay-at-home order right like
that's what we've been in stage two is
opening lower-risk work places like
schools and child like big hairs and
stuff like that stage three is higher
higher risk workplaces like gyms and
nail salons and all that stuff and then
stage four would be the end of the
stay-at-home order I worry about the
hookers in Amsterdam why because they're
at the riskiest place I heard they're
doing the infrared scan boy really likes
kidding oh oh you don't have a fever oh
[ __ ] you scan their dicks my friend told
me he's out in the Europe area but he
told me that one of his friends I was
like are you sure it's not you and he's
like no it's not me but he frequents a
brothel for sure yeah he's like I swear
it's not me and I was like okay like why
do you have the [ __ ] emphasize that
he goes but he's like he's like
basically what one of the people that
that his friend is a regular with
offered a 30% discount
Elena oh it's rough a discount like
that's a pretty good discount it's
really good that's how that's rough
times yeah cuz ten is like oh like we
might feel the effects thirty is almost
half price that's a deal
what I'm like what are they doing how
does that work to use this gamma barcode
or something I have a coupon it's
nothing but weird babies all old-school
old with cash but but is it exactly 30%
because does that mean it's like not an
even number and you have to
bring change in shape okay their usual
[ __ ] services like 275 yet they do
the math what is the math than 30% of
sit there with her calculate that number
I like this idea where it's like a
pointy to five every time you go to
Subway you get a little card well maybe
she's like like a Bobo shop or maybe in
her head to like you know help balance
it out she only like maybe like sucks
the dick for half the time because you
would have no idea going into it how
long she was gonna suffer
stripping with a two-for-one special two
songs for one but then they collaborate
with a DJ and a DJ songs are matched or
special now what or what they would do
at the strip club is like they'd be like
oh yeah by 2 for 1 3 for 1 special but
the songs are like 20 seconds that's how
to get this that's how they get you but
then sometimes you get the wrong
stripper and you're like this song is
long Queen song no I have a couple of um
stripper homegirls I'm like man they're
struggling right now what are they doing
fans because I heard that market it's
all only family only fan make sure so
they know so heavy well they know how
credible are news always so I want to
make sure we get the right URL at that
that's true because people really really
want us to be spot-on with the facts and
they get really mad if we don't because
we are respectable news channel we're I
think we get the facts right more than
CNN so what the hell ah no I mean I use
my journalism degree all the time like
Hello degree yeah oh yeah [ __ ] I don't
think you're being truthful right now
hmm well that's what happens when you
don't have a degree
damn there was this gym owners petition
going around cuz I think like a lot of
the mom-and-pop gyms they got hit like
or what we got a head like the hardest
was it called the
the the lettuce work out let us work out
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
those legal documents that you file it's
not even a petition I lost the word now
so much what it was all for an article
in the [ __ ] and for a law but it was
like you're going down an escalator bill
yeah I don't know but they're trying to
get I think it was like fifteen thousand
signatures it just California alone so I
signed it a bunch of other people sign
dicks I think from the government's
perspective they're seeing like a big LA
Fitness the same as they're seeing our
small gym teacher petite gym and our gym
only has maybe twenty eight only has a
twenty or thirty people
I like the T better yeah so you petite
gym you were like don't clump us in with
these big old anyway one of my favorite
genres by the way I never type bookie
I never - I never type that I look for
petite I go I go back and forth through
you know I do a spectrum of petite to
BBW bbws huge oh yeah I like pogs
Papapa gives a fat ass white girl pawg
oh that's also a category they in some
countries they're considered overweight
many countries yeah except America it
was crazy I even remember being a little
kid loving booties even from a young age
right and then washing like blind date
or something with my dad and then the
girl got in a bikini my dad's like oh
man she's that's too big watch your
crazy me too I was like why do people
not like butts yeah what's wrong with
that
and the best [ __ ] to is that probably
your mom's behind them in like the
[ __ ] ass so goddamn I don't like dad
look at mom's fat ass kidding me you
like that dope [ __ ] he does that's the
thing yeah well anyway right now
currently back to this whole California
and like opening up conversation we are
in stage 2 which means retail is open
and like office workplaces and it is
limited like limited personal services
and outdoor museums and all that stuff
like I guess they said Runyon is open
now right in Kenya yeah hiking thank God
we can start seeing influencers post
again on Runyon Canyon yeah wasn't
getting makeup please yes get back to it
you know I've never been and I've always
been curious you've never been to the
Runyon it sucks it's a it's a fun little
hike oh it's not cool hike like the
Griffith Observatory one way you can
actually get a decent I like the Runyon
because when you go the opposite way
it's kind of like difficult cuz you know
a lot of people go actually making it
one way now what yeah oh the traffic
oh that's annoying because a tow truck
normally like you can go up the way
that's more of a gradual hike and then
you kind of skip down the rocks yeah but
if you go up the skip rocks way it's
like oh [ __ ] man this is this is crazy
you're the first person I've heard talk
about the actual trail itself usually I
hear like all running is great like it's
great for networking
that's real yeah I did Wow [ __ ]
makeup running down their neck as they
like I'm serious it's crazy are they
looking for a husband no they're a low
maybe but they're usually there to try
to like you know mingle sometimes yeah I
mean I see yeah for the pictures for
sure there's a bunch of celebrities that
go there too so I think people just
looking for anything but it's a good
hike I I liked general there's no chick
there's no trees though there's no trees
dry
hi more betrayal yeah I'm saying it's
more like a it's like it's a dirt rocky
run like a walkway it's authentic SoCal
though that is that is the high king of
SoCal that's what you get out here
you're not wrong yeah it's a desert
desert yeah we put this here we put the
trees it wasn't like this none of the
trees are natural yeah all the palm
trees are that's why all our [ __ ]
trees are weird image mismatch there's
like nothing that's really pretty
all the trees are immigrants just like
the people well maybe it's beautiful
because it's miss Macedon perfect geo
you ever think of that
oh no I didn't I'm glad you brought that
up Yoji live here in a perfect world
yeah it is and we're like hey cool it
I like cellulite on my booties I don't
get it some stretch marks you don't get
it you see beautiful palm trees when
you're cruising down a lane and you look
down and there's a crackhead taking a
dump on one of them that's that's LA and
they're both immigrants anyway yeah so
what kind of procedures are you guys
gonna implement in barbel ask her I
don't know because she said yeah gyms
can open next week in parts like what
[Laughter]
yeah we're gonna do [ __ ] like cashless
transactions um we're gonna do like
appointment only it's gonna be like uh
so like few people at a time then we
have to close midday and like this in
fact everything yeah it's gonna be
pretty gnarly oh that's all the bar also
what schools all of our stations are
already six feet apart some of them most
of them are like eight to ten so I think
that part so what if people just want to
drop by and then it's not their schedule
what happens then I think we'll go are
there any police years so what are what
do they do
do they just make an appointment be like
can I come at this time and then they
come back you go online we met yeah
exactly they would go online and then
like whatever slot timeslot they want to
reserve and then there
the time slot for like an hour dance is
usually like a lot of the workouts like
two hours mm-hmm we'll see we'll see
maybe they can do after now I'm like
good I don't care what I did nine quick
it's been an hour
let's go even though I sat in the Sun
over 20 minutes and Mike I may be job
buddy watch the basketball game by
texting for ten minutes it's time to go
[Music]